outbreaks in high risk settings such as
hospitals and long-term care homes
our wastewater surveillance is still
showing the majority of sites in the
province have downward or stable trends
in sars kovi ii detections although we
continue to see some regional variation
especially in the north and are
monitoring fluctuations in this data
with the peak of omicron behind us
ontario has been able to cautiously and
gradually move through its reopening
milestones we are now learning to live
with and manage cover 19 for the long
term
this necessitates a shift to a more
balanced response to the pandemic and
changes are being made with respect to
the province pandemic response to
reflect a longer term approach
foreign
with continued improvements in trends
ontario will remove the mandatory
masking requirement for most settings on
march 21st with the exception of select
settings such as public transit
health care settings long-term care
homes
and high-risk congregate care settings
removing the mask mandate does not mean
the risk is gone
covet 19 transmission is still occurring
across the province and mass can help
protect you and others becoming from
becoming infected with covet 19.
in fact we can expect indicators such as
cases and hospitalizations to increase
slightly as ontario increases
increasingly interacts with one another
however thanks to our high vaccination
rates and natural immunity that is
developing as well as the arrival of
other therapeutics and antivirals
ontario has the tools necessary to
manage the impacts of this virus
for those most vulnerable to the virus
it is still strongly recommended that
you continue to wear a mask
and please continue to respect the
masking requirements that remain in
place
such as federal requirements for
returning international travelers
as a society i am asking that we remain
kind considerate and respectful towards
those who continue to choose to wear a
mask
and we should all be prepared that we
may need to resume mask wearing if a new
variant of concern emerges or
potentially during the winter months
when covid and other respiratory viruses
are likely to circulate again
on tuesday march 1st i revoke the
instructions for mandatory covet 19
vaccination policies for the ontario
public service and for post-secondary
institutions
a process is now underway to gradually
revoke all directives and instructions
by the end of april
with a focus on moving away from
emergency measures to ongoing operations
moving away from reliance on provincial
emergency direction through mandatory
requirements providing consistent
guidance both across and within sectors
and ensuring support for the most
vulnerable
are removed last and lifting of measures
in a coordinated
fashion for case and contact management
i want to spend a moment to go over some
of the changes that have been made in
our approach to case and contact
management and isolation requirements
the guidelines are being updated to
minimize the burden on workers and
families while ensuring our highest risk
settings continue to be protected
the changes include updating isolation
recommendations for household members
and close contacts of individuals who
test positive for cova 19 or have
symptoms of covet 19
previously everyone in the household of
someone who was sick or had tested
positive had to stay home as well
with these new changes household members
do not have to stay at home if they are
18 years or older and have already
received their booster dose or if they
are 18 years of age and under and are
fully vaccinated
these household members still need to
wear a mask outside the house and avoid
vulnerable people in high-risk settings
like long-term care homes for 10 days
but they can continue to go into work
and or school
as long as they're asymptomatic
for those non-household members who have
been in close contact with someone with
covet 19 you are no longer required to
self-isolate regardless of your
vaccination status you do have to
self-monitor for 10 days wear a mask
when outside the house avoid activities
where mask removal would be necessary
and avoid vulnerable individuals in high
risk settings like hospitals
these requirements for masking or of
recovering cases and contacts still
apply when there are no longer masking
requirements in the general community
if you have symptoms of covid19 you
still need to isolate right away and get
tested via a pcr if eligible or rapid
antigen test if you have access to one
for those who choose to get boosted not
only are you better protected from covet
19
but as long as you do not have any
symptoms you are no longer needed to
isolate if someone in your household is
sick
education as we continue to ease public
health measures we're also working with
the ministry of education to align
measures in schools and child care with
those in the community as much as
possible and as of march 21 schools and
child care providers will no longer be
required to conduct on-site verification
of screening for all children students
and staff
children students and staff still
self-screen before attending school or
child care every day and stay at home if
they are experiencing any new or
worsening symptoms of illness
the province is also aligning with
changes to community measures including
eliminating cohorting and distancing
requirements and in alignment with
community masking requirements masks
will no longer be required of children
students and staff or visitors in child
care schools school board offices and or
student
transportation just as in the community
should individuals choose
or are required to continue to wear a
mask at school or child care i would ask
that we respect and be supportive of
these decisions
the government will continue to provide
free masks and personal protective
equipment for staff and students that
choose to wear them in both school and
child care settings
while these measures are being lifted
the government has also made 3.6 million
rapid antigen tests available to school
boards and child care settings every two
weeks
and these shipments of rit's will
continue to support symptomatic testing
for students staff and children
they will also be provided to staff and
students who return from an unplanned
absence staff and students can also
access rit's via
participating community
supports this is my last schedule
scheduled weekly covet 19 update and i
want to thank ontarians for their
resilience and commitment to community
as we've navigated this global pandemic
together your sacrifices and collective
actions have made a difference
i also want to acknowledge that friday
march 11th is the national day of
observance to honor those who have lost
their lives because of covet 19. over 6
million people globally to the friends
families and communities who have lost
loved ones i offer my
sincere and heartfelt condolences
i also want to recognize everyone who
has been impacted by covet 19 and thank
our dedicated front-line workers for
their incredible sacrifices in our fight
against this virus while i may not be
delivering updates every week my team
and i remain steadfast in our commitment
to protecting the health and safety of
ontarians and we will closely and
carefully monitor kova 19 trends across
the province we will not hesitate to
take action should the situation change
and will inform ontarians of any
significant developments the lifting of
public health and workplace safety
measures and the end of weekly updates
does not signal that kovid 19 has
disappeared or that the pandemic hit is
over what it means is that we have come
to a place where we know what we need to
do to manage this virus and to keep each
other safe we need to remain vigilant we
need to stay home when we're sick and
most importantly we need to get
vaccinated and boosted vaccination is
the best protection against covet 19 and
the best protection for the progress we
have made bianca significa
and thank you mercy
happy to take questions
dr moore
thank you
um
we're not doing pcr testing or virtually
no pcr testing there's no rt value
uh
there's sewage water yes but are the
mass being removed for our mouths and
now being put over our eyes how are
people going to be able to assess
their own risk
so we have very much a robust
surveillance strategy in ontario we'll
continue to have on the ontario.ca
website uh the updates to
hospitalization
across ontario what proportion of those
hospitalizations are caused by and
happily the percent is decreasing on a
weekly basis we're now around 45 percent
of admissions are caused by uh kovit-19
we'll also clearly update the icu
impact
from covet 19.
we will be publishing the percentage
positivity of the pcr tests that are
done and we still have a robust pcr
testing strategy at around 20 000 doses
or 20 000 tests
a day
and that percent positivity
is remaining relatively stable
as well on the ontario
science table dashboard they are
updating the surveillance from
septic so i do believe we have a robust
surveillance strategy public health
ontario will also be publishing the
strain and strain dominance
and as you know um the whole genome
sequencing remains quite robust we'll
also be partnering with our federal
counterparts to understand what strains
could be imported into canada and we'll
be making that information available on
a regular basis as well so i'm confident
in our surveillance strategy uh health
units for the 34 regions across our
province will be updating their websites
to inform the public about the overall
risk in their communities and the
percent positivity and the rate of
illness rate of detection of positivity
doctor how confident are you that you
had enough data to make a decision like
this on masking well i think we've been
following the trends uh ever since we've
uh experienced this the start of omicron
so to go back um we we peaked around the
third week of january in ontario and
have had a peak in hospitalizations in
icu at around 4 000
and 6 hundred admissions to the
intensive care unit uh since that time
we've seen slow and steady declines
despite opening up so on the 17th of
january we opened up our schools uh on
the 31st of january we further opened up
the economy 17th went to full capacity
for
most venues and then march 1st full
capacity for the large venues so despite
that progressive phased staged approach
we haven't seen a sudden rebound on
cases or impact on the health care
system so our strategy has worked in
that meanwhile we worked very diligently
to increase the third dose so over seven
million ontarians protected with third
doses and our immunization rate at a
population level for 12 and up is around
90 over 90 percent
so ontarians have come forward they've
gotten immunized and protected we now
have more therapeutics available across
our clinical assessment centers and
despite progressive phase and staged
reopening we've not seen a significant
rebound in impact on our health system
so i will monitor the situation in an
ongoing fashion as we do
but i feel confident that we can do this
safely i also though want to encourage
all ontarians to continue to wear masks
if they are vulnerable to this virus if
they've got any underlying illness if
they
are immune suppressed in any way
and for us to remain kind to consider it
to anyone that wants to continue to wear
their mask it is now a choice not a
mandate
and i hope anyone that remains
vulnerable will continue to wear their
masks
on march 3rd the children's health
coalition including chio and sick kids
had said had asked for you to wait two
weeks after the return of uh after march
break in order to lift any other public
health measures i understand that you
may have met with them as recently as
yesterday why was their advice to wait
two weeks not taking
oh we're in regular conversation with
the children's health coalition have to
thank them for the advice that they
provided an ongoing basis to my office
as well as to the ministry um i think
they agree that the trends across
ontario are very good that the risk of
hospitalization to children has been
minimal um in in that very few children
have had to be admitted as a cause for
covid and or
into the intensive care unit i think
today there's only three children across
2.75 million that are in the intensive
care unit
and
for the vast majority they're recovering
uh and and going back into the community
quickly
so i think they've realized the health
impact
because of our strong immunization
strategy it has been very good
and minimized that the hospital impact
has been minimized they were happy to
hear that 91 percent of high school
students have their two doses that 55
percent of five to elevens have had uh
their first dose and
half of them have come forward to get
their second dose so our robust
immunization strategy has worked for our
schools they were also happy to hear
that we continue to invest in hepa
filters so 49 000 additional hepa
filters have been purchased and will be
distributed across the education sector
that we continue to invest in
environmental health cleaning that we're
encouraging every child to screen on a
daily basis prior to coming school that
we have one of the most robust rit
strategies with 3.6 million
rat tests being distributed to schools
uh every other week across ontario so
they were very happy with that strategy
yes we'll have debate about when to open
um
but they had to agree that the impact on
our health system which is what all
public health measures are intended to
prevent
has worked that our immunization
strategy has worked
and that although there are differences
in opinion uh the health impact uh on
our system has been minimized
how can you say that the timeline for
all this isn't political when all the
measures are basically ending right
before the election campaign is going to
start so i just want to assure ontarians
that uh
my decision-making and recommendations
to government have not been affected by
any understanding of the political
system that they are based on evidence
in science and that we followed a phased
and staged approached i just outlined
the dates that we've followed we've been
doing every two weeks that we've had
phase and stage reopening it has gone
very safely this phase we're waiting
three full weeks
to remove the last measure which is the
the masking in public in public spaces
although i hope all ontarians will
continue to be kind and considerate and
allow those that choose to wear a mask
to continue to go forward in wear masks
especially if you're vulnerable to this
virus
no go ahead um i was just wondering
other than telling people to be kind to
one another have you made any
recommendations to the government to
make sure that there's no you know
intimidation uh with people that decide
to keep wearing their mat yeah i think
we have to have a robust education
strategy regarding
when to wear a mask and who
vulnerable individuals to this virus
should continue to wear masks so anyone
that has had
immune suppression that's been a
transplant patient that has an
underlying chronic illness or is older
should continue to wear a mask
and that communication strategy will be
promoted through our local public health
agencies through direct communication to
school boards and to the public
and it starts here with this discussion
i want all ontarians to remain
considerate and kind to those that
choose to wear a mask
it is a means of protecting each other
uh and reducing personal risk and it has
worked for us in the past doctor peter
uni has been quoted this morning as
saying not only does he think politics
may be playing a role here but he
believes this decision is premature are
you no longer
taking advice from the head of the
science table sir well i'm in regular
contact with dr juni i'm also in regular
contact with my my team which is
an excellent team within the ministry
and i meet regularly with my federal
provincial and territorial uh colleagues
and we just met yesterday our our plan
to remove masking aligns uh is is even
more cautious than most provinces if you
look across jurisdictions
and it fits along with our phased and
staged approach in ontario that follows
evidence that follows risk
and
i i think a federal provincial and
territorial comparison will reveal that
we've been quite cautious in removal of
these public health measures
we could have to go back to masks uh
perhaps in the fall when we get to
colder weather what benchmarks would you
be looking for before you would do that
on a profit scale or even a regional
scale well thanks for that question so
we're going to maintain a robust
surveillance system going into the fall
and we're going to have a testing
strategy that will allow through pcr to
detect multiple different viruses so
whether it's influenza a influenza b rsv
and or covid19 and that surveillance
system will be put in play through
emergency departments
to end primary care to be able to detect
when the viruses start circulating
and if we're seeing multiple different
viruses circulating and and we can
anticipate those four which typically
each one has a significant impact on the
health system uh to to co-circulate that
we would make recommendations uh to mask
at that time if we see an increasing
burden on the hospital system despite a
potential immunization strategy for
influenza and or for covid we may make a
move from a recommendation
to a mandate for masking but that would
follow data it would follow
the surveillance the circulation of
those viruses and the impact on the
hospital before we'd ever make a
recommendation to mandate and we'd move
in a progressive fashion for first
informing the public uh educating them
about the benefits of masking and then
potentially potentially to uh to a
mandate
we wouldn't keep this in place for
elementary schools where we haven't seen
the rate of vaccination that we've seen
in high schools why not keep it in place
longer in elementary schools doctor so
um just to reinforce it's now a choice
and i hope parents choose to mask
if their child is vulnerable to this
virus the good news is that over 50
percent 55 percent have had their first
dose and the vast majority of those are
going to have their second dose that the
risk to hospitalization of those
children from 5 to 11 is quite low that
the measures that we put in place in
schools have worked i'm so happy to
announce so we've had only one closure
of a school in ontario of the 4844
schools as of yesterday so the measures
are working
and i do think that the increase in air
quality the the investment in improved
ventilation hepa filtration uh cleaning
as well as the investment of testing uh
for all students will continue to keep
our schools safe dr dr uni what he said
this morning was that he'd like to see
more data before the decisions made and
i mean the point i think he made was uh
we've only seen uh would have been seven
eight days now since the march first
loosening so how confident how can you
be confident that
that we're not going to see a bump from
that we're only we're only barely a week
past that that then
yeah so that was only one phase of the
reopening if we go back
for our progressive reopening that we've
had in ontario's school openings on
january 17th didn't see a significant
rise the reopening of the economy on the
31st of january the further reopening
for 100 capacity on february 17th we did
not see a significant rise uh in
transmission and in cases and or
hospitalization so um
it's anticipated we have not seen any
significant signals as well since march
1st and we're not monitoring this data
on a very close basis
that we will continue uh
given these trends
not to have any significant rebound like
we had in january the main point has
been to prevent
the impact on the hospital system i
thank all ontarians for coming forward
for having one of the highest
immunization rates uh in the world uh
seven million additional ontarians have
come forward with their third doses
which further protects our hospital
system protects against
admission to hospital
and severe complications of covet 19 and
i absolutely encourage in the coming
12 days that if you haven't had your
third dose
please come forward and get it
what are you going to do on march 21st
personally when you go into a mall when
you meet with co-workers when you
you know go anywhere maybe a hospital
where what are you going to do are you
personally going to go mask free from
the 21st onwards or are you going to
continue to wear your grass oh great
question so in outdoor settings
absolutely i won't be wearing my mask
and i will do a risk assessment for high
risk indoor settings so if i go to the
eaton center
i'll wear my mask if i'm on the subway
it'll be mandated in or public bus or
streetcar i will continue to wear my
mask in those environments
if i go to a busy busy uh
box store i'll put my mask on in those
settings i i
i don't want to give away any of my
personal health information but i'll do
my individual risk assessment uh and if
i'm going into that type of environment
uh where you're not gonna have
distancing other people aren't wearing
masks uh at an individual level i'll
continue why would you do that why would
you do that if you're telling 15 million
ontarians it is safe to remove your mask
why would you personally choose to wear
your mask if you go to costco it is a
choice now and that's the the major
change on the 21st that you can do your
individual risk assessment is not a
mandate the risk is is continuing
diminish
but for some individuals that may be at
risk to admission to hospital and or
have a negative impact from covet 19
that's their decision and choice to make
and that's where we move from a mandate
to choice
in the lead up to this you've said many
times that you want people to be nice to
people who keep wearing masks and you
start call today for an education push
about that
what are you expecting is going to
happen this is something you've
reiterated for weeks that people need to
be nice to people who are going to
continue wearing masks are you
anticipating that there will be
harassment what what is the concern here
well i i think we've been watching the
news uh internationally and
and from the united states where there's
an intolerance in some communities in
some societies i would like us to be
tolerant of people's individual choices
and to realize we're not finished with
this pandemic that the the risk of the
virus continues and that
we have to acknowledge that some people
will be quite concerned with the removal
of a mask mandate
and that we should give them the option
of wearing a mask and wearing a mask in
confidence
that
they will be treated with appropriate
kindness and consideration uh and with
no judgments being made and i think
that's an educational piece that um we
we can all work on as a community i
think we've remained very uh tolerant uh
and kind and considerate throughout this
pandemic
in in ontario i would just like to see
that continue
could you explain what you're
recommending in terms of mandatory
vaccination policies and why
so as of uh
march
14th
we have removed any letters of
instruction for immunization policies uh
in uh various venues so on the first we
remove them for from the ontario public
service as well as from colleges and
universities on the 14th we're remu
removing immunization policies uh in
other sectors knowing that each one of
those sectors
and private or corporations can
adopt
their own immunization policies going
forward but a mandate from
us to have immunization and or testing
is now being removed given that the risk
is less and in many instances i want to
thank those
workers in those environments that have
come forward they have very very high
immunization rates
saying that it's actually safe for an
unvaccinated person to work in a
long-term care home because that's one
of the the mandatory policies that's
going to end on the 14th like can you
actually explain the science behind that
so so first of all that they
they have a directive from the minister
that they have achieved 100
immunization of two doses for all
workers in their sector a significant
proportion i think it's in the 80s have
come forward and gotten their third
doses in that sector the most important
component now going forward is
maintaining that high level of
immunization and immunity but also
adhering to all best practices in fact
infection prevention and control and and
i think
that has to be operationalized across
the long-term care and retirement home
sector
and we're going to work with them to
ensure that there's a smooth transition
from a directive or letter of
instruction
to operationalizing all the lessons
learned from the pandemic
[Music]
if you want to be safe
but we've been told the whole pandemic
that it works we're wearing them to
protect others so what's changed about
the science now that you'll be protected
if only you are wearing one but everyone
else in this room is it so the risk now
is is less than it was in the first
second or third week of january
and because the risk is less
our public health recommendations have
to be proportionate they have to be
balanced
and you have to recognize you can't
mandate masking forever that it has to
be eventually an individual choice based
on an individual's risk assessment and
we're at that point by march 21st
that we're asking ontarians to do an
individual assessment
acknowledging that the risk remains
but that we're well over the peak of
activity across ontario
and we have to learn to live with this
virus many have been infected
already and recovered many have had
their third doses
and are prepared to
not have to mask
in public spaces
and we have to acknowledge that they
have that right now
to not have to wear a mask
and that each individual has to do their
own risk assessment thank you everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]